Badminton is a game played as singles...
...where one person plays against one person...
...or doubles where two people play against two people.
The object of the game is for you or your team to win two sets...
...faster than the opposing team.
To win a set, you must score 21 points and be at least two points ahead.
To start the game, the player must serve the shuttlecock below the waist.
The shuttlecock must travel over the net...
...and land in the areas defined for the serve to be legal.
If the shuttlecock is hit onto the lines, this also counts as a point.
The opponent will then try and return the shuttlecock...
...and make you miss returning it back.
This can go back and forth and is known as a rally.
Remember, the aim of the game is to hit the shuttlecock...
...onto your opponents floor,...
...and these are the areas you're aiming for.